European Union ministers have reached
broad agreement on priorities and ways
to share funds for the e use fishery
sector over the next seven years the
talks in brussels the ministers decided
on rules for the european maritime and
Fisheries fund a new budget created to
help fishermen adapt to the latest
reforms the epithelia verbal this is a
crucial decision for the european
fisheries sector large because the new
fund will enable us to implement the
reform of the Common Fisheries Policy
the agreement on the full general
approach will enable the presidency to
start negotiations with the European
Parliament de la paz euro rekulu a major
overhaul of the e used fisheries policy
was agreed in May the changes also
include a potentially costly obligation
to land all commercial catches and the
scientific monitoring of fish stocks the
so-called e mff funding envelope is a
key part of the reforms some of the
money could be used to fund startups for
young fisherman or to help renovate
small-scale and coastal fishing vessels
more than 35 years old the package is
aimed at bringing Europe's dwindling
supplies of fish back to sustainable
levels and providing citizens with a
safe predictable and healthy food supply
the european parliament's fisheries
committee approved its vision of the
operating rules for the EMF f which will
total more than 6 billion euros on july
10 negotiations between the council and
parliament are set to begin in autumn